OK.
cameras are rolling.
This is lecture fourteen,
starting a new chapter.
Chapter about orthogonality.
What it means for
vectors to be orthogonal.
subspaces to be orthogonal.
What it means for
bases to be orthogonal.
So ninety degrees, this is
a ninety-degree chapter.
So what does it mean --
let me jump to subspaces.
Because I've drawn
here the big picture.
This is the 18.06 picture here.
And hold it down, guys.
So this is the picture and we
know a lot about that picture
already.
We know the dimension
of every subspace.
We know that these
dimensions are r and n-r.
dimensions are r and m-r.
What I want to show now is
what this figure is saying,
that the angle --
the figure is just my attempt to
draw what I'm now going to say,
that the angle between these
subspaces is ninety degrees.
And the angle between these
Now I have to say
what does that mean?
What does it mean for
subspaces to be orthogonal?
But I hope you appreciate
the beauty of this picture,
that that those
subspaces are going
to come out to be orthogonal.
Those two and also those two.
So that's like one point,
one important point
to step forward in
understanding those subspaces.
We knew what each
subspace was like,
we could compute bases for them.
Now we know more.
Or we will in a few minutes.
OK.
I have to say first of all what
does it mean for two vectors
to be orthogonal?
So let me start with that.
Orthogonal vectors.
The word orthogonal is
-- is just another word
for perpendicular.
It means that in
n-dimensional space
the angle between those
vectors is ninety degrees.
It means that they
form a right triangle.
It even means that the going
way back to the Greeks that this
angle that this triangle
a vector x, a vector x,
and a vector x+y -- of course
that'll be the hypotenuse,
so what was it the Greeks
figured out and it's neat.
It's the fact that the --
so these are orthogonal,
this is a right angle, if --
so let me put the great
name down, Pythagoras,
I'm looking for --
what I looking for?
I'm looking for the condition if
you give me two vectors, how do
I know if they're orthogonal?
How can I tell two
perpendicular vectors?
And actually you
probably know the answer.
Let me write the answer down.
Orthogonal vectors, what's
the test for orthogonality?
I take the dot product which I
tend to write as x transpose y,
because that's a
row times a column,
and that matrix multiplication
just gives me the right thing,
that x1y1+x2y2 and so on, so
these vectors are orthogonal
if this result x
transpose y is zero.
That's the test.
OK.
Can I connect that
to other things?
I mean -- it's just beautiful
that here we have we're in n
dimensions, we've got
a couple of vectors,
we want to know the
angle between them,
and the right thing to look at
is the simplest thing that you
could imagine, the dot product.
OK.
Now why?
So I'm answering the
question now why --
let's add some justification
to this fact, that's the test.
OK, so Pythagoras would say
we've got a right triangle,
if that length squared plus
that length squared equals
that length squared.
OK, can I write it as x
squared plus y squared equals
x plus y squared?
Now don't, please don't think
that this is always true.
This is only going
to be true in this --
it's going to be equivalent
to orthogonality.
For other triangles of
course, it's not true.
For other triangles it's not.
But for a right triangle
somehow that fact
should connect to that fact.
Can we just make
that connection?
What's the connection between
this test for orthogonality
and this statement
of orthogonality?
Well, I guess I have to say
what is the length squared?
So let's continue on the board
underneath with that equation.
Give me another way to express
the length squared of a vector.
And let me just
give you a vector.
The vector one, two, three.
That's in three dimensions.
What is the length squared of
the vector x equal one, two,
three?
So how do you find
the length squared?
Well, really you just, you want
the length of that vector that
goes along one -- up
two, and out three --
and we'll come back to
that right triangle stuff.
The length squared is
exactly x transpose x.
Whenever I see x
transpose x, I know
I've got a number
that's positive.
It's a length
squared unless it --
unless x happens to
be the zero vector,
that's the one case
where the length is zero.
So right -- this is just x1
squared plus x2 squared plus
so on, plus xn squared.
So one -- in the example I gave
you what was the length squared
of that vector one, two, three?
So you square those, you
get one, four and nine,
you add, you get fourteen.
So the vector one, two,
three has length fourteen.
So let me just put
down a vector here.
Let x be the vector
one, two, three.
Let me cook up a vector
that's orthogonal to it.
So what's the vector
that's orthogonal?
So right down here, x squared
is one plus four plus nine,
fourteen, let me cook up a
vector that's orthogonal to it,
we'll get right that that
-- those two vectors are
orthogonal, the length
of y squared is five,
and x plus y is one
and two making three,
two and minus one making one,
three and zero making three,
and the length of this squared
is nine plus one plus nine,
nineteen.
And sure enough, I
haven't proved anything.
I've just like checked to
see that my test x transpose
y equals zero, which
is true, right?
Everybody sees that x
transpose y is zero here?
That's maybe the main point.
That you should get really
quick at doing x transpose y,
so it's just this plus this
plus this and that's zero.
And sure enough, that clicks
with fourteen plus five
agreeing with nineteen.
Now let me just do
that in letters.
So that's y transpose y.
And this is x plus y
transpose x plus y.
OK.
So I'm looking, again,
this isn't always true.
I repeat.
This is going to be true
when we have a right angle.
And let's just --
well, of course,
I'm just going to
simplify this stuff here.
There's an x transpose x there.
And there's a y
transpose y there.
And there's an x transpose y.
And there's a y transpose x.
I knew I could do that
simplification because I'm just
doing matrix multiplication and
I've just followed the rules.
OK.
So x transpose x-s cancel.
Y transpose y-s cancel.
And what about these guys?
What can you tell me about
the inner product of x with y
and the inner
product of y with x?
Is there a difference?
I think if we -- while
we're doing real vectors,
which is all we're doing now,
there isn't a difference,
there's no difference.
If I take x transpose
y, that'll give me zero,
if I took y transpose x I would
have the same x1y1 and x2y2
and x3y3, it would be
the same, so this is --
this is the same as
that, this is really
I'll knock that guy out
and say two of these.
So actually that's the --
this equation boiled down
to this thing being zero.
Right?
Everything else canceled
and this equation
boiled down to that one.
So that's really all I wanted.
I just wanted to check that
Pythagoras for a right triangle
led me to this -- of course
I cancel the two now.
No problem.
To x transpose y equals
zero as the test.
Fair enough.
OK.
You knew it was coming.
The dot product of
orthogonal vectors is zero.
It's just -- I just want
to say that's really neat.
That it comes out so well.
All right.
Now what about -- so
now I know if two --
when two vectors are orthogonal.
By the way, what about if one of
these guys is the zero vector?
Suppose x is the zero
vector, and y is whatever.
Are they orthogonal?
Sure.
In math the one thing
about math is you're
supposed to follow the rules.
So you're supposed to --
if x is the zero vector,
you're supposed to take the
zero vector dotted with y
and of course you
always get zero.
So just so we're all
sure, the zero vector
is orthogonal to everybody.
But what I want to --
what I now want to think
about is subspaces.
What does it mean for me to
say that some subspace is
orthogonal to some
other subspace?
So OK.
Now I've got to write this down.
So because we're defining
definition of subspace
S is orthogonal so to
subspace let's say T,
so I've got a
couple of subspaces.
And what should it mean for
those guys to be orthogonal?
It's just sort of what's
the natural extension
from orthogonal vectors
to orthogonal subspaces?
Well, and in
particular, let's think
of some orthogonal
subspaces, like this wall.
Let's say in three dimensions.
So the blackboard extended
to infinity, right, is a --
is a subspace, a plane, a
two-dimensional subspace.
It's a little bumpy
but anyway, it's a --
think of it as a subspace, let
me take the floor as another
subspace.
Again, it's not
a great subspace,
MIT only built it
like so-so, but I'll
put the origin right here.
So the origin of the
world is right there.
OK.
Thereby giving linear algebra
its proper importance in this.
OK.
So there is one subspace,
there's another one.
The floor.
And are they orthogonal?
What does it mean
for two subspaces
to be orthogonal and
in that special case
are they orthogonal?
All right.
Let's finish this sentence.
What does it mean
means we have to know
what we're talking about
here.
So what would be a reasonable
idea of orthogonal?
Well, let me put
the right thing up.
It means that every vector
in S, every vector in S,
is orthogonal to --
what I going to say?
Every vector in T.
That's a reasonable
and it's a good
and it's the right
definition for two subspaces
to be orthogonal.
But I just want you to see,
hey, what does that mean?
So answer the
question about the --
the blackboard and the floor.
Are those two subspaces,
they're two-dimensional, right,
and we're in R^3.
It's like a xz plane or
something and a xy plane.
Are they orthogonal?
Is every vector in the
blackboard orthogonal
to every vector in the floor,
starting from the origin
right there?
Yes or no?
I could take a vote.
Well we get some
yeses and some noes.
No is the answer.
They're not.
You can tell me a
vector in the blackboard
and a vector in the floor
that are not orthogonal.
Well you can tell me
quite a few, I guess.
Maybe like I could take
some forty-five-degree guy
in the blackboard, and
something in the floor,
they're not at ninety
degrees, right?
In fact, even more,
you could tell me
a vector that's in both the
blackboard plane and the floor
plane, so it's certainly
not orthogonal to itself.
So for sure, those two
planes aren't orthogonal.
What would that be?
So what's a vector that's --
in both of those planes?
It's this guy running
along the crack
there, in the intersection,
the intersection.
A vector, you know --
if two subspaces meet at some
vector, well then for sure
they're not orthogonal,
because that vector is in one
and it's in the other, and
it's not orthogonal to itself
unless it's zero.
So the only I mean
so orthogonal is
for me to say these two
subspaces are orthogonal first
of all I'm certainly saying
that they don't intersect
in any nonzero vector.
But also I mean more than
that just not intersecting
isn't good
enough.
So give me an example, oh,
let's say in the plane, oh well,
when do we have orthogonal
subspaces in the plane?
Yeah, tell me in the
plane, so we don't --
there aren't that many different
subspaces in the plane.
What what have we got in the
plane as possible subspaces?
The zero vector, real small.
A line through the origin.
Or the whole plane.
OK.
Now so when is a line
through the origin orthogonal
to the whole plane?
Never, right, never.
When is a line through the
origin orthogonal to the zero
subspace?
Always.
Right.
When is a line through
the origin orthogonal
to a different line
through the origin?
Well, that's the case that
we all have a clear picture
of, they --
the two lines have to
meet at ninety degrees.
They have only the -- so
that's like this simple case
I'm talking about.
There's one subspace,
there's the other subspace.
They only meet at zero.
And they're orthogonal.
OK.
Now.
So we now know what it means for
two subspaces to be orthogonal.
And now I want to say that
this is true for the row
space and the null space.
OK.
So that's the neat fact.
So row space is orthogonal
to the null space.
Now how did I come up with that?
But you see the rank it's
great, that means that these --
that these subspaces are
just the right things,
they're just cutting
the whole space up
into two perpendicular
subspaces.
OK.
So why?
Well, what have I
got to work with?
All I know is the null space.
The null space has vectors
that solve Ax equals zero.
So this is a guy x.
x is in the null space.
Then Ax is zero.
So why is it orthogonal
to the rows of A?
If I write down Ax
equals zero, which
is all I know about
the null space,
then I guess I want you to
see that that's telling me,
just that equation right
there is telling me
that the rows of A,
let me write it out.
There's row one of A.
Row two.
Row m of A. that's A.
And it's multiplying X.
And it's producing zero.
OK.
Written out that
way you'll see it.
So I'm saying that a
vector in the row space
is perpendicular to this
guy X in the null space.
And you see why?
Because this equation
is telling you
that row one of A multiplying
that's a dot product, right?
Row one of A dot product with
this x is producing this zero.
So x is orthogonal
to the first row.
And to the second row.
Row two of A, x is
giving that zero.
Row m of A times x
is giving that zero.
So x is --
the equation is
telling me that x
is orthogonal to all the rows.
Right, it's just sitting there.
That's all we -- it had to
be sitting there because we
didn't know anything more
about the null space than this.
And now I guess to be
totally complete here
I'd now check that
x is orthogonal
to each separate row.
But what else strictly
speaking do I have to do?
To show that those
subspaces are orthogonal,
I have to take this x in
the null space and show that
it's orthogonal to every
vector in the row space,
every vector in the
row space, so what --
what else is in the row space?
This row is in the row space,
that row is in the row space,
they're all there, but it's
not the whole row space,
right, we just have to
like remember, what does it
mean, what does that
word space telling us?
And what else is
in the row space?
Besides the rows?
All their combinations.
So I really have to
check that sure enough
if x is perpendicular
to row one,
row two, all the
different separate rows,
then also x is perpendicular
to a combination of the rows.
And that's just matrix
multiplication again.
You know, I have row
one transpose x is zero,
so on, row two
transpose x is zero,
so I'm entitled to multiply that
by some c1, this by some c2,
I still have zeroes,
I'm entitled to add,
so I have c1 row one so --
so all this when I put that
together that's big parentheses
c1 row one plus c2 row two
and so on.
Transpose x is zero.
Right?
I just added the
zeroes and got zero,
and I just added these
following the rule.
No big deal.
The whole point was
right sitting in that.
OK.
So if I come back to this figure
now I'm like a happier person.
Because I have this --
I now see how those
subspaces are oriented.
And these subspaces
are also oriented.
Well, actually why is
that orthogonality?
Well, it's the same
statement for A transpose
that that one was for A.
So I won't take time
to prove it again
because we've checked
it for every matrix
and A transpose is just
as good a matrix as A.
So we're orthogonal over there.
So we really have
carved up this --
this was like carving
up m-dimensional space
into two subspaces and
this one was carving up
n-dimensional space
into two subspaces.
And well, one more thing here.
One more important thing.
Let me move into
three dimensions.
Tell me a couple of orthogonal
subspaces in three dimensions
that somehow don't carve
up the whole space,
there's stuff left there.
I'm thinking of a couple
of orthogonal lines.
If I -- suppose I'm in
three dimensions, R^3.
And I have one line, one
one-dimensional subspace,
and a perpendicular one.
Could those be the row
space and the null space?
Could I be in three
dimensions and have
a row space that's a line and
a null space that's a line?
No.
Why not?
Because the dimensions
aren't right.
Right?
The dimensions are no good.
The dimensions here, r and
n-r, they add up to three,
they add up to n.
If I take --
just follow that example --
if the row space
is one-dimensional,
suppose A is what's
a good in R^3,
I want a one-dimensional row
space, let me take one, two,
five, two, four, ten.
What's the dimension
of that row space?
One.
What's the dimension
of the null space?
Tell what's the null space
look like in that case?
The row space is a line, right?
One-dimensional, it's just a
line through one, two, five.
Geometrically what's
the row space look like?
What's its dimension?
So here r here n
is three, the rank
is one, so the dimension
of the null space,
so I'm looking at
this x, x1, x2, x3.
To give zero.
So the dimension of the null
space is we all know is two.
Right.
It's a plane.
And now actually we know, we
see better, what plane is it?
What plane is it?
It's the plane that's
perpendicular to one,
two, five.
Right?
We now see.
In fact the two, four,
ten didn't actually
have any effect at all.
I could have just ignored that.
That didn't change the row
space or the null space.
I'll just make
that one equation.
Yeah.
OK.
Sure.
That's the easiest to deal with.
One equation.
Three unknowns.
And I want to ask --
what would the equation
give me the null space,
and you would have
said back in September
you would have said
it gives you a plane,
and we're completely right.
And the plane it gives
you, the normal vector,
you remember in calculus, there
was this dumb normal vector
called N.
Well there it is.
One, two, five.
OK.
What is the what's the
point I want to make here?
I want to make --
I want to emphasize
that not only are the --
let me write it in words.
So I want to write the null
space and the row space are
orthogonal, that's this
neat fact, which we've --
we've just checked
from Ax equals zero,
but now I want to say more
because there's a little more
that's true.
Their dimensions add
to the whole space.
So that's like a little
extra information.
That it's not like
I could have --
I couldn't have a line and
a line in three dimensions.
Those don't add up one and
one don't add to three.
So I used the word orthogonal
complements in R^n.
And the idea of
this word complement
is that the orthogonal
complement of a row space
contains not just some vectors
that are orthogonal to it,
but all.
So what does that mean?
That means that the null
space contains all, not just
some but all, vectors that are
perpendicular to the row space.
OK.
Really what I've done in this
half of the lecture is just
notice some of the
nice geometry that --
that we didn't pick up before
because we didn't discuss
perpendicular vectors before.
But it was all sitting there.
And now we picked it up.
That these vectors are
orthogonal complements.
And I guess I even
call this part
one of the fundamental
theorem of linear algebra.
The fundamental theorem
of linear algebra
is about these four
subspaces, so part one
is about their dimension, maybe
I should call it part two now.
Their dimensions we got.
Now we're getting their
orthogonality, that's part two.
And part three will be
about bases for them.
Orthogonal bases.
So that's coming up.
OK.
So I'm happy with that
geometry right now.
OK.
Now what's my next
goal in this chapter?
Here's the main
problem of the chapter.
The main problem of the chapter
is -- so this is coming.
It's coming attraction.
This is the very last
chapter that's about Ax=b.
I would like to solve
that system of equations
when there is no solution.
You may say what a
ridiculous thing to do.
But I have to say it's
done all the time.
In fact it has to be done.
You get -- so the
problem is solve --
the best possible solve I'll
put quote Ax=b when there is no
solution.
And of course what
does that mean?
b isn't in the column space.
And it's quite typical if this
matrix A is rectangular if I --
maybe I have m equations and
that's bigger than the number
of unknowns, then for
sure the rank is not m,
the rank couldn't be m now, so
there'll be a lot of right-hand
sides with no solution,
but here's an example.
Some satellite is buzzing along.
You measure its position.
You make a thousand
measurements.
So that gives you a thousand
equations for the --
for the parameters that
-- that give the position.
But there aren't a
thousand parameters,
there's just maybe
six or something.
Or you're measuring the --
you're doing questionnaires.
You're measuring resistances.
You're taking pulses.
You're measuring
somebody's pulse rate.
There's just one unknown.
OK.
The pulse rate.
So you measure it
once, OK, fine,
but if you really
want to know it,
you measure it multiple times,
but then the measurements have
noise in them, so there's --
the problem is that
in many many problems
we've got too many
equations and they've got
noise in the right-hand side.
So Ax=b I can't expect to
solve it exactly right,
because I don't
even know what --
there's a measurement
mistake in b.
But there's information too.
There's a lot of information
about x in there.
And what I want to do is like
separate the noise, the junk,
from the information.
And so this is a straightforward
linear algebra problem.
How do I solve, what's
the best solution?
OK.
Now.
I want to say so that's
like describes the problem
in an algebraic way.
I got some equations, I'm
looking for the best solution.
Well, one way to find it
is -- one way to start,
one way to find a solution
is throw away equations until
you've got a nice, square
invertible system and solve
that.
That's not satisfactory.
There's no reason in
these measurements
to say these
measurements are perfect
and these measurements
are useless.
We want to use all
the measurements
to get the best information,
to get the maximum information.
But how?
OK.
Let me anticipate a matrix
that's going to show up.
This A is typically rectangular.
But a matrix that shows
up whenever you have --
and we chapter three was all
about rectangular matrices.
And we know when
this is solvable,
you could do elimination
on it, right?
But I'm thinking hey,
you do elimination
and you get equation zero
equal other non-zeroes.
I'm thinking we really --
elimination is going to fail.
So that's our question.
Elimination will
get us down to --
will tell us if there
is a solution or not.
But I'm now thinking not.
So what are we going to do?
OK.
All right.
I want to tell you to jump
ahead to the matrix that
will play a key role.
So this is the matrix that
you want to understand
for this chapter four.
And it's the matrix
A transpose A.
What's -- tell me some
things about that matrix.
So A is this m by n matrix,
rectangular, but now
I'm saying that the good
matrix that shows up in the end
is A transpose A.
So tell me something about that.
Is it -- what's the first thing
you know about A transpose A.
It's square.
Right?
Square because this is m
by n and this is n by m.
So this is the result is n by n.
Good.
Square.
What else?
It's symmetric.
Good.
Because you remember
how to do that.
If we transpose that
matrix let's transpose it,
A transpose A, if
I transpose it,
then that comes first
transposed, this comes second,
transposed, and then transposing
twice is leaves it --
brings it back to the
same so it's symmetric.
Good.
Now we now know how to
ask more about a matrix.
I'm interested in
is it invertible?
If not, what's its null space?
So I want to know about --
because you're going to see,
well, let me -- let me even,
well I shouldn't do this,
but I will.
Let me tell you what
equation to solve
when you can't solve that one.
The good equation comes
from multiplying both sides
by A transpose, so the good
equation that you get to
is this one.
A transpose Ax
equals A transpose b.
That will be the central
equation in the chapter.
So I think why not
tell it to you.
Why not admit it right away.
OK.
I have to --
I should really give x.
I want to sort of indicate that
this x isn't I mean this x was
the solution to that
equation if it existed,
but probably didn't.
Now let me give this a
different name, x hat.
Because I'm hoping this
one will have a solution.
And I'm saying that
it's my best solution.
I'll have to say
what does best mean.
But that's going to
be my -- my plan.
I'm going to say that the best
solution solves this equation.
So you see right away why I'm
so interested in this matrix
A transpose A.
And in its invertibility.
OK.
Now, when is it invertible?
Let me take a case, let me
just do an example and then --
I'll just pick a matrix here.
Just so we see what A
transpose A looks like.
So let me take a matrix A
one, one, one, one, two, five.
Just to invent a matrix.
So there's a matrix A.
Notice that it has M equal three
rows and N equal two columns.
Its rank is --
the rank of that matrix is two.
Right, yeah, the
columns are independent.
Does Ax equal b?
If I look at Ax=b, so x is
just x1 x2, and b is b1 b2 b3.
Do I expect to solve Ax=b?
What's -- no way, right?
I mean linear algebra's
great, but solving
three equations with
only two unknowns usually
we can't do it.
We can only solve it if
this vector is b is what?
I can solve that equation
if that vector b1 b2 b3
is in the column space.
If it's a combination of
those columns then fine.
But usually it won't be.
The combinations
just fill up a plane
and most vectors
aren't on that plane.
So what I'm saying is
that I'm going to work
with the matrix A transpose A.
And I just want to figure
out in this example what
A transpose A is.
So it's two by two.
The first entry is a three,
the next entry is an eight,
this entry is --
what's that entry?
Eight, for sure.
We knew it had to
be, and this entry
is, what's that now, getting out
my trusty calculator, thirty,
is that right?
And is that matrix invertible?
Thirty.
There's an A transpose A.
And it is invertible, right?
Three, eight is not a
multiple of eight, thirty --
and it's invertible.
And that's the normal,
that's what I expect.
So this is I want to show.
So here's the final --
here's the key point.
The null space of
A transpose A --
it's not going to be
always invertible.
Tell me a matrix --
I have to say that I can't
say A transpose A is always
invertible.
Because that's asking too much.
I mean what could the
matrix A be, for example,
so that A transpose
A was not invertible?
Well, it even could
be the zero matrix.
I mean that's like extreme case.
Suppose I make this rank --
suppose I change to that A.
Now I figure out A transpose
A again and I get --
what do I get?
I get nine, I get nine
of course and here I
get what's that entry?
Twenty-seven.
And is that matrix invertible?
No.
And why do I --
I knew it wouldn't
be invertible anyway.
Because this matrix
only has rank one.
And if I have a product
of matrices of rank one,
the product is not going to
have a rank bigger than one.
So I'm not surprised that
the answer only has rank one.
And that's what I --
always happens, that the
rank of A transpose A
comes out to equal
the rank of A.
So, yes, so the null
space of A transpose A
equals the null space of A,
the rank of A transpose A
equals the rank of A.
So let's -- as soon as
I can why that's true.
But let's draw from that
what the fact that I want.
This tells me that this square
symmetric matrix is invertible
if --
so here's my conclusion.
A transpose A is invertible
if exactly when --
exactly if this null space
is only got the zero vector.
Which means the columns
of A are independent.
So A transpose A is
invertible exactly
if A has independent columns.
That's the fact that I
need about A transpose A.
And then you'll see next
time how A transpose A
enters everything.
Next lecture is
actually a crucial one.
Here I'm preparing
for it by getting us
thinking about A transpose A.
And its rank is the
same as the rank of A,
and we can decide
when it's invertible.
OK.
So I'll see you Friday.
Thanks.